[Music]
how is the dating in Los Angeles
disaster why describe a big nightmare
describe some of your dates
okay um guy comes over to my house we
have a nice day comes over laughs into
my mouth when he's kissing me laughing
and he laughs we're making out he's like
what's up bud he's like nothing I'm like
are you laughing he's like no laughing
into your mouth he's like I gotta get
out of here I'm sorry I gotta go any
left yeah another guy making out on my
couch he stands up he puts his shoes on
he exits my apartment
hey no talk walked a make out he got
away just what's going what it witnessed
miss there's something going on in your
apartment that we don't know about is
there like a several bears head in there
the best the best dating story was so I
was like okay I'm gonna try online
dating I'm just gonna go for it you know
what I mean
you want to know website I went on a
website went out on a date with this guy
it was good he was tall he was he was he
had a job so that's I mean it's already
a step up for me right and so I get a
second date and he takes me to the
Angels Blue Jays games and I'm a huge
Blue Jays fan a huge baseball fan he
gets like really expensive tickets so
I'm like okay okay guys really going for
it he's like why don't why don't I go
back to your house play a board game in
my mind I'm like that's kind of a lame
way to get back into my place but I've
given it up for less you know what I
mean
it's been a slow fall when it's already
winter so anyway so he comes over we
play Scrabble I school him you're
welcome yeah so we're sitting on the
couch and then he like he kind of is
like leaning against me kind of like
this I'm here and then he just slowly
turns his nose into my armpit and like
buries it in there and just like did you
just smell my armpit and he was like
yeah it's like does it smell bad and he
was like doesn't smell good like you
wearing men's deodorant and I was like
yeah why business why you wear men's
deodorant
and I read that Mindy Kaling does too
and that makes me feel like we would be
besties okay yeah anyways he sniffs Iran
and then he's like well it's getting
late looks like I'm gonna have to sleep
here and because I'm an idiot I was like
okay but nothing's gonna happen so we
sleep in my bed nothing happens he
leaves and I say I texted I'm like I
don't think it's gonna work out he
writes back immediately and he's like
yeah I agree and I was like okay buddy
whatever an hour passes I get a photo
text message it's a picture of a loaf of
bread with a post-it note on it that
says free help yourself and the text he
has attached is this was in the kitchen
at my office today it's nice to know
there's still some good in the world
what website were you on was OkCupid
that was gone was worse because I went
on a match like on date within five
minutes the guy was like yeah you know I
went to Thailand I've got a $15.00
[ __ ] from a Thai hooker no big deal
and then he's like you're judging me
you're judging me aren't you and I was
like no I don't judge you I judged the
slave trade yeah no no no it was a nice
hotel I'm sure they're well taken care
of which is also what you say but zoo
animals yeah right they're well taken
care of
right away into a date that he got a
five minutes five minutes into a date he
told you about that and he's like you
want to come home with me and I was like
no not really he's like let's get the
bill then what's the point
[Music]
no horrible
[Applause]
all over town there's armpits that ain't
sniffing yeah he stole my move
[Laughter]